Slavic mythology and folklore is known
for its unusual creatures and today we
will discuss three of my personal
favorites the dama voya house dwelling
guardian spirits often linked to a
family rather than the house itself the
appearance of the dama voice varies from
a small gray bearded elderly man
to a dwarf like creature with horns and
a tail he can often be found at the
center of the house underneath a stove
however the Dhamma void prefers to be
heard rather than seen the Dhamma voice
seeks to maintain order and peace
throughout the home if treated well he
will help with chores around the house
and has been known to bring good luck
leaving the Dhamma voids favorite food
such as milk bread and porridge is often
appreciated and will keep the house
spirit happy if a dumb boy is angered
they will behave much like a poltergeist
haunting the family and sometimes even
injuring pets and cattle a cold touch
from a dumber voice often foretells of
misfortune the snuffing out of a candle
or the visual manifestation of the
Dhamma boy can signify the pending death
of a family member
less she are spirits of the forest they
are the protectors of the forest and
anything inside the lessee are known for
having a strong bond of animals they are
often seen being accompanied by either a
gray wolf or a bear the Alessia
shapeshifters and they can transform
into any animal or plant in the forest
their natural form often resembles a
large man sometimes covered in leaves
they have long hair and their beards are
often made of living grass and vines
their long limbs and their grassy facial
hair means that the leshy camouflage
well and can often be mistaken for a
tree the less you stand their tallest at
the center of the forest the further
they stray the smaller they become once
they reached the edge of the forest
Valecia tiny and can even hide under
leaves less he may not be evil but they
are indeed tricksters they have been
known to mislead travelers and cause
them to become lost in their forest they
rarely cause harm to travelers but they
have been known on rare occasions to
have too much fun and accidentally kill
their victims
if one befriends alesci they will learn
the secrets of their magic farmers and
Shepherds would often give Leslie the
cross around their necks as a gift and
in return the less she would protect
their crops and sheep the Bannock is a
bathhouse spirit often obsessive
cleanliness the third or fourth room in
a bathhouse was often reserved for the
Bannock
the Banat could often invite demons and
forest spirits to share its bath there
were no Christian images allowed in both
houses as to not offend the Bannock or
its guests if a person interrupted a
banach while it was washing the Bannock
would often pour boiling water on them
or even strangle them in the steam the
Bannock had the ability to predict the
future you would stand with your back
exposed to the benek if your future was
prosperous the Bannock would gently
stroke your back
however if trouble lay ahead the Bannock
would strike of its claws if you've
enjoyed this video then please go ahead
and leave it a like consider subscribing
if folklore mythology is something that
interests you if you have anything you'd
like to discuss or have any ideas for
future videos then please go ahead and
let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained
[Music]